So let me get to sort of a a tour of reactions
to Donald Trump's claim that he's taking hydroxy
chloroquine prophylactically. Again, I don't
know that we believe it. Trump shouldn't be
taking it, but he also may be lying by talking
about it. He's creating. He has already created
a shortage for people who actually need this
medication for approved uses like lupus and
malaria. It's unproven as a corona virus prophylactic.
And Trump doesn't have any of the conditions
that this drug is actually approved to treat.
But he claims to be taking it. So last night,
Nancy Pelosi, Democratic speaker of the House,
says, listen, this drug has adverse reactions
under the sort of cardiac umbrella and Trump's
morbidly obese, so he shouldn't be taking
it. Take a look at this.
As far as the president is concerned, the
our our president and I would rather he not
be taking something that has not been approved
by the scientists, especially in his age group
and in his, shall we say, weight group that
is morbidly obese. So I I think that it's
not a good idea.
So this immediately triggered a whole span
of reactions. Some people gleefully going
all the way up to bordering on fat shaming
Trump. Other people reacted furious that Nancy
Pelosi would be making such baseless claims
about Trump's morbid obesity. So let's go
through this item by item. Hydroxy chloroquine
has a number of adverse effects. It includes
cardiac arrhythmias, hypoglycemia and a number
of neuro psyche, psychiatric effects. If you
have a cardiovascular deficiency, which Donald
Trump does, he is overweight. We'll talk about
obesity in a moment. This is a drug you should
probably avoid unless totally necessary. It's
clearly not necessary for Donald Trump to
take this if he is indeed taking it now. It
also causes a bunch of neuropsychiatric symptoms.
It includes agitation, insomnia, confusion,
mania, hallucinations, paranoia, depression,
catatonia, psychosis, suicidal ideation. What's
interesting about that is Trump already exhibits
a whole bunch of those. So we may not even
be able to tell the difference. Trump is regularly
agitated. He claims to sleep only a few hours
a night. He's regularly confused. His Twitter
use is completely manic. He's completely paranoid.
You get the idea. So now we get to the question,
is Pelosi right that Trump is morbidly obese?
Trump claims to be six foot three inches tall
and weigh two hundred and thirty nine pounds.
That would put you at a BMI of twenty nine
point nine. The line for obesity is 30. Now,
I know BMI is very flawed, but for most people,
you know, Trump is not a bodybuilder, for
example, where BMI doesn't work. It's a pretty
good rule of thumb. So the suspicion is Trump
claims to be 63 to 39, because that puts him
literally one pound from being obese. And
we know Trump is not six foot three inches
tall. You can look at Trump in pictures with
other people whose heights we know. For example,
Justin Trudeau, the Canadian prime minister,
is 6 foot 2. Trump is clearly shorter than
Trudeau in pictures. And we've got a bunch
of examples. So if Trump is 6 1 and 2 39,
he's obese. Trump is more likely 6 1 and to
60, he is higher in obesity. However. He is
not morbidly obese. Usually we use some combination
of your 100 pounds overweight, you have a
BMI above 40 or a BMI above 35 with obesity
related conditions like diabetes or blood
pressure. Trump, even at 6 1 to 60, has a
BMI of thirty four point three. So listen,
guys, Nancy Pelosi was wrong. Donald Trump
is not morbidly obese by any reasonable definition.
He is certainly obese and he should not be
taking prophylactic hydroxy chloroquine. So
that gets us once again back to the question
of is Trump really taking it? What doctor
would prescribe for an older obese guy with
a heart problem? Something that is ineffective
in preventing Corona virus and increases the
rate of cardiac arrhythmia. Final takeaway
is we don't know whether Trump is on this
and we may never know. But fortunately, at
least one Fox News host is sounding the alarm
about what Donald Trump claims
to
be doing.